what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
abba and preach he destroyed her on live
tv for money before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification about the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
okay before i start um
sorry hold on
i know the videos have been slow lately
i've been traveling i'm moving to europe
in like a week and guys i'm so tired i'm
so tired
but i have a couple videos for you this
week arizona
sound is working okay
he was born in wisconsin and has five
brothers and sisters he was asked over
50 questions by a polyglot oh my gosh i
used to love this show i was so sad when
they discontinued it examiner 21 have
been chosen for tonight tonight you
brought family and friends here as well
let's meet them
hi i'm marie curtis's mom that haircut
is how you know this is an old show yeah
you don't see that haircut unless you
watch i was like cheers
hi i'm aurora
i'm cody curtis's little brother i'm
john curtis's friend question six for
ten thousand dollars
do you tell your friends intimate
details about the women you date oh no i
don't wanna know
oh i wouldn't wanna know oh i wouldn't
want to know
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you feel to know that i know that
he's told me that he never he doesn't do
that really yeah
oh
people talk this is the one thing i've
noticed i've like learned in life is
someone always talks to someone
like some people talk to more people
than others
but someone always said something to
someone
when bro looked up to the sky
it gave it away excuse me yeah look at
his face right now he went
gabby and he told her he told her what
she needed to hear yeah she seems really
nice too
and he's looking at him like oh you're
not even gonna hide your face
[Applause]
[Music]
aurora
how do you feel to know that he might
know that he's told me that he never he
doesn't do that really yeah
[Music]
oh man he's like when did i say that
you ain't double wing
do you tell your friends intimate
details about the women you date yes or
no
yes
you do i do
[Music]
oh he's gonna be the dog house
cody john have you heard any of these
details before
don't answer that one we already know
moving on to the next answer he's just
like i remember what the [ __ ] told me
looked like
i think i know the answer already yeah
yeah
you've heard what's telling the truth
what what what guy doesn't right
um
no
no
no no no
no i mean there's definitely people who
do oh yeah but that's something that's a
no problem no sir oh that's a no keep it
private it's how you keep keep problems
away
that's oh my gosh that's the older i get
that's
that's what i've learned more and more
and more being in like a super public
relationship
it's better to keep more stuff off the
internet
because if you guys can do a fight or
something and you have to like explain
it later
like
oh gosh it's hard especially as a girl i
feel like we always want to talk to each
other but
the older again i'm like oh i should
talk to them last find out if that
answer is true or false
that answer is
why she already crying at the first
question that's the first one boo boo
you you are not gonna last you are not
gonna like you guys you are not gonna
like this episode today's video is
sponsored by wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew say it with us now blue chip it's
time for you to get dollar shipping
that's bluechew.com using promo code
abba and get your first answering this
video question
11. have you ever told someone you'd
been tested for a sexually transmitted
disease when in fact you hadn't
there's a bunch of people at home being
like
yeah ladies if there's any ladies
watching this plan channel that is the
one thing that you literally cannot play
with
do not have unpredicted unprotected sex
with a guy until
like you know he's been tested
you can literally not have a kid from
that stuff
yeah he's in the cringe zone how are we
going to survive now also ladies if you
do get tested right away like i feel
like girls these days do not get tested
enough we have too much to lose yeah you
can do this
these questions are ruthless he's at 11.
yes
that answer is
[Music]
[Applause]
i need to do something for this because
it's killing my face her face nah
it's like when you try not to cry
she's trying not to go out she's trying
so hard she's trying so hard it's not
working have you ever stolen money from
the family business
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't want to know you can hit the
button do you want him to hit the button
you want me to hit it
[Music]
dang so okay it's like they know they
just don't want everyone to know because
if you have to hit the button you know
not answering the question is answering
the question
even if it's them that's what i said
guys oh my god
like best friends
you know we all know because you know
okay do you secretly want to get back
together with your girlfriend aurora um
or is her
yeah
thanks girl we're sitting there
that's his ex-girlfriend that's his
ex-girlfriend
oh that's his axe
i think she's doing it after all this
this brings her if i can smile oh my god
girl she's too innocent oh
wow girl what do you think his answer
will be aurora um
i don't know
no he's gonna say no
uh my answer is yes
[Applause]
now you're clapping and you're good
[Applause]
she's a wonderful girl i'd love to
love to be with her
i love her
she's so pretty she seems like such a
sweet girl
he does it though you could do better
sis who broke up with whom this this
time
um it was mutual we both obviously not
too mutual
any chance that this relationship will
rekindle
um you never
question 15
for 100 000
while you were dating your former
girlfriend aurora did you ever cheat on
her
uh the order of these questions we all
know we all know the answer like i could
tell you just by his vibe it was perfect
no
we know we'll never know oh we'll know
aurora any thoughts on this
um
i don't think he ever did
well there's no button to save you now
you have to answer this truthfully or
lose your 25 000.
yes
oh look at her face
oh
[Applause]
national tv huh i need to walk out
that answer
is true
[Music]
this is not good
our night of parting is just going down
the tubes
are not a partying has just gone down
the tubes this [ __ ] was trying to get
lit
when yo where's that l.a uh where did it
be vegas when vegas went to l.a we're
with new york whatever we're gonna get
lit after oh [ __ ] we're not gonna get
none of that order before that's perfect
before you wanna get back with her hell
yeah oh
did you ever tutor life together
yeah yeah
i did so
oh man this show was so good at
destroying people
that's not the answer you wanted to hear
hon aurora no
i'm sorry to see you uh
you know tearing up it's okay we have a
word for this it's called mesquine
you know what someone's like hurting
like they're like a little puppy like
yeah that's what she is right now she's
biscuit i feel bad don't you feel bad
for her no no no some people are just
innocent like they don't know anybody
you don't feel bad for them no no it's
like that's life there's innocent people
we need them oh no
i love
he's like no
um
[Music]
but it's out there now
and uh here good thank you
aurora is this something we can come
back for
you know what she looks like you know
those kids are getting beat when they
get told they can't cry
they're just sitting there with their
face
are you going to cry
no no
sir
[Music]
three more truthful answers you double
that money to 200 000
that's a lot of money you know the
questions you were asked maybe the ones
you were most worried about
like that last one are out and done the
damage is done so maybe it's smart to
continue
uh maybe it isn't only you can answer
that question what do you want to do
[Music]
that's it he came on he embarrassed her
got his money and then left
200 000 is pretty good good night party
let's go
hookers overall no all right
that's exactly it that's exactly it
moral of the story
if your ex invites you on a dating show
don't go she suffered all the emotional
backlash for nothing and she's not gonna
die damn
i love these reaction videos because i
don't have to do any of the clipping and
stuff it's just like ready
um
yeah
wow
i'm speechless to be honest like
ah that was so uncomfortable let me know
in the comments what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell i'll talk to
you guys next time